because you know look we you know doing
research on eunuchs so we're gonna go
into all these different times in
history but I found this story from the
first century around about a very famous
eunuch named Boris
Espio are us now this it's safe to say
this kid had a little bit of a rough
life that didn't stop he had a rough
life this this story that I'm about to
tell you is about sports his rough life
but also about the [ __ ] complete
insanity of nero so make no mistake what
I'm about to tell you guys is [ __ ]
wild and is 100% true unfortunately
okay so like I said castration was a big
no-no under run all under Roman law in
the first century you just couldn't do
it it was outlawed but then Nero comes
along and understand one thing about
Nero he did not give a [ __ ] about laws
now he lived life in his own [ __ ]
lane you think Donald Trump doesn't give
a [ __ ] about what he says about him
dams times that by a million yeah Nero
okay so Nero saw himself above the law
and he just decided to castrate spores
yeah sports no don't make no mistake
Sports was just some Roman kid walked
off on like Roman teenager walking
around the streets of Rome and was just
pulled off the street and castrated
immediately he was probably a really
cute kid
yeah well here's what happened so no
people really don't know about sports
his background except that he was a
young man who you know Nero just liked
and probably thought he was killed so
Nero decides to castrate sports and then
make listen to what I'm about to tell
you Nero decides to castrate sports
who's a guy of course and then make
spores his wife gonna castrate a man I'm
not openly gay but I'm gonna make sports
my [ __ ] wife and I'm the emperor of
Rome and you could do nothing and then
their marriage included a ceremony where
he gave steam a horse where a bride's
veil he gave her a dowry and afterwards
he threw all he threw them a wonderful
honeymoon in Greece okay if you think
gender fluidity was a big thing now it
was huge with Nero's
yeah time yeah and they're saying that
Nero probably married spores because
Nero himself was feeling guilty because
about a month before that
make no mistake Nero did in fact kick
his pregnant wife Sabina to death he
ejected to death and he said that's
Spore s bore an uncanny resemblance to
Sabina and he had to have her and he
even used to call spores by his dead
name by his dead wife's name Sabina
unfortunately so you know what that
means that means that is probably why
spores was chosen and that's probably
why he was castrated he is the [ __ ]
unluckiest kid that lived during Nero's
errand he was probably just walking down
the street and crazy [ __ ] Nero was in
his chariot and he happened to look out
his window and he said is that [ __ ]
Sabina and they said no your Emperor
Sabino you kicked her to death who
kicked her to death in the stomach and
killed her and your unborn child yeah he
said oh I'm sorry I must have forgot
about that I'm [ __ ] wild and crazy my
name's near oh no that's Sabina bring
him to me and then they brought that
thing into his chariot and they said let
me see his puss and they said oh he's
got your Emperor that is not Sabina it
has a dick and he said give me this
scissors not anymore
that is the most unfortunate kid to ever
walk yeah I sit here
yeah and feed me his balls like [ __ ]
grass yeah you telling me he's not
subpoena give me scissors now he is yeah
and here's how [ __ ] wild Nero was
this podcast is not about here we'll get
back to unit shortly but I just need to
tell you a sidebar I have [ __ ] a wild
Nero was so I told you that he just
randomly pilled pick spores off the
street cut his nuts off it said marry my
wife but make no mistake Nero also did
marry two other men in his life and they
were not castrated in those marriages
because Nero wanted to be the wife Thank
You Thomas De Niro was married three
times
twice as twice as a wife and once as a
husband
so Nero is [ __ ] wild Nero takes your
[ __ ] gender fluidity yeah [ __ ]
pees on it yeah he was the most
gender-fluid [ __ ] of all time
yeah and also the story does go that
unfortunately one day and 68 AD somebody
told Nero that they had ran out of
grapes and cheese and
you did in fact kill himself immediately
and he jumped a little window and killed
himself as the sitting emperor of Rome
because they ran out of grapes and
cheese momentarily
yeah yeah you could go to Nero and say
to him Nero there are 137 genders and he
would go are you [ __ ] crazy but not
because he thought there was only two
genders he would go there's [ __ ] four
thousand and sixty-six genders yeah yeah
yeah bring me all the grapes and cheese
yeah I'm [ __ ] eunuchs you can I'm a
[ __ ] horse and jump out a window yeah
[Music]